c'est quoi te confessé 30 mois et les
années que ça n'est pas arrivé je pense
à téter alcoolique
ouais tu buvais combien d'argent quand
je me suis arrêté je lui ai près d'un
avis de whisky par jour
je buvais pour me donner du courage pour
monter sur scène ont donné le courage
d'affronter les ennuis jusqu'au jour où
je me suis aperçu que c'est pour
l'alcool qui donne le courage de
remonter sur scène
ni d'affronter les ennuis avec un peu de
volonté ça va aussi
depuis un moment c'est quoi ya pas
longtemps tellement de pression des
journal des mecs autour qu'il juge sans
arrêt quittant tué par terre te laisse
même pas le temps de te relever parce
que depuis qu'il m'est arrivé des
emmerdements et qu'on gagne ils n'ont
pas n'ont pas laissé souffler quoi ta
faiblement pour arrêter l'alcool net
tout seul non seulement je roule anglais
j'arrête je me mets deux ans à la faute
et je me suis deux ans en afrique tu
craques jamais ah non mais je peux pas
si l'idée de prendre une cuite me
terrifie j'ai plus du tout nous
réveiller le matin avec la tête présent
comme je l'avais avant est ce que tu
crois qu'on peut rire de tout
non et quand tu dis par exemple en
parlant de ton fils qui est mort dans un
accident de moto il a trop bien imiter
coliche ça c'est sur le coup parce que
le rire est une thérapeutique que je
conseille à tous
j'ai même dit anna qui ont mal tourné ll
n'y a pas tourné du tout à propos de
cette non tu as dit depuis je suis en
survie oui personne leur donnera mon
gamin la plaie est ouverte à vie je ne
serai plus jamais pleinement heureux je
suis cassé dans ces moments là t'as pas
été tenté par l'idée de te raccrocher à
dieu plutôt qu à l'humour
non non parce que je me raccroche aux
gens tu crois pas en dieu tu pense
toujours qu'il n'a rien à voir rien
après comme tu le dis sera oui je pense
que rien à voir rien après je pense je
pense parce que même aux moments les
plus durs je les pensais pas ce que
c'était vraiment une occasion de penser
qu'ils avaient quelque chose lui en
disant aux cours et des mois ou plus
mais même là je n'ai pas pensé tu
pouvais changer le monde plus vrai quoi
si je devais changer le monde je me
changerait moi d'abord pourra totalement
apte à changer monde
les corrections de ne rien rater de il a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus